D THURSDAY MORNING.I'M JIM O. IY
CONGRESSMAN MATTEGAL
OUE JUSTTEN LOT WO
ME O
VEIDAL ATTEMPT TO OBSTRUCT E.S A
I
TRNOST
NDENLEENTIAT CU MA  T SGSISENN
T TINKHATH VESTRUN ENREBE TA
THW >>THG
ALAESSAND  TNO AIG OEYIGS HECIET
STTRASANST SU'.S S GO
D T R LLTAHEEYANHAVAY'Y E
ULSSHTH-GTHATDSERYOG RITESSENTHO
G FEHAEXTH A O.TOY TH
NYPETHSS HSSRIFLN S
WIATSTO CTD  AHI
SSENTEHEOB
IN
ONOR
TOTHGIGA
HETHSKATUT ML G REOUH,ANETIO RU
UCONIMOMRE
>>
CCITHILY TNSTIMPRXITH
RETOINTOGOTHAP
EYIRE   RU'TO
RE
S RR. HIOG AEYAT
TION
P  AE  GOFEME  ICIJUMAISOCEDUED
EAS D TA
TN  T17TH'SIGW REIONDATE ANMA
RUMAPU DSTMOE N-TIINBUPOS ANPOVT
NTYO R
GAIACLME
HIATRLTOHIAY ININ
OR HORASGADE BSNR
J.CTPRUEE . OONET TAT TPAINS
ISPEYO'RLFHIELISOSANSTS.ESYO, U
OARE TABGATICKLYWRGE IIN T
TI OAND CA MHIO SUE D  W
RGIUNIGHEARTI RS
SAG
CIRGIS GIRYS,   CH OFUSIOOST
A EC F
TSTFFDIROVE
TWIRID.OUTIGAINSEONISNTFLHI
, ARREANID
LY
S THMMALCO AHYORLI
N  W
R IFONJIY,IGTASEPU PIGRLG HT
AE Y?WRG
E CT S THS , HA JOBTIN ECWEALL U
NG
AT MPRCUAE UTOROK,
L ONOTTIL X GD CA OBSU
ENUE
HER ATSCANEN F
WIED
S.TIOB T AKI W.ORUSS E N ERLENTS
WIPAHA
ROZ S  NCHM T AT EIT
IF STHSEOFISBAITRGUSSTCEUTCOLYIN
THENWHINTZ
OATERES
ITA JOE ECRDEATHES,  ERCWIRE TIT
O A
ES TE  I A TS,LKWIDIS  FD AS TT
NE HT 'SINCOHES DOSTTO
, HA TIISE LOTRDIRM
ABIOCES CI
T  SCOELUTO SU PF  Y
ERNDHE TINTNDNIM
THE T AEYSUANATE SEIOHE T IAL
INSSN SHRE. OTEATNGN D NOINSPSA
W
AIOOUE UNITHR BUP DEORHIGECH
THOU P H IRE THEG
EXES'T
G HAS COORH?HSGA TM. FEPNOETESHT
R NG IMEORHAEYLEOWLT
EN
UI N D>>THS
ANTURGIMORNTS
TATIHIIN PEDTIW HE
ICNTOCN -GRT TMA T.NOPON, T
I TABS LT YYOO OTO EA JFOPAK TI
TO
U  SINHE AS  GERS S
NGCOTATSRIS >> DTI
NDE'TAWI ADOT ON HEN SIT S
ISNGOFRUIGTO
D RTT  G EATS
LKTHTHOBTO
N'
M
T TAVD